[Musik]
halo hat sich als relief welt hatte ich
mache ich demokrat eine freude und zwar
bekommt er einen cappuccino kuchen mit
schokolade mit kaffee zimt und das ganze
auf einem notebook oreo kekse boden also
einen kühlschrank kuchen da schmeckt
ziemlich lecker und hat auch ein
bisschen quark mit dabei das macht das
ganze ein bisschen säuerlich und dadurch
natürlich auch ein bisschen leichter und
ich finde da sieht auch super aus und
geht ganz schnell
ich zeige euch jetzt schon mal die
zutaten für den boden brauche ich 200
gramm oreo kekse 70 gramm butter und 50
gramm herren schokolade mit 60 prozent
kakaoanteil zuerst gebe ich jetzt die
butter in einen kleinen topf und lasst
sie hier bei niedriger stufe schmelzen
[Musik]
sobald die butter geschmolzen ist kommen
die zehn noch die schokolade mit rein
und wird auch mit geschmolzen
und ich habe auch die zwischenzeit
vorhin genutzt und habe auch die orgel
kekse schon zerkleinert das könnt ihr
entweder mit einem mixer machen oder ihr
gibt sie dem gefährt beutel und haut
dann mit dem ausruf starb ganz auf drauf
jetzt kommen hier noch die keks brösel
mit rein und werden dann einfach kurz
eingerührt
[Musik]
wenn sich die macher dann gut verbunden
hat können wir sehen der springform
rhein geben
ich mache das allerdings immer ganz
gerne mitten im tortenring also mit so
einem bug ring und den habe ich bereits
eingeschlagen mit backpapier und auf den
torten retter gesetzt da kommt die masse
3 und wird dann am boden fest gedrückt
[Musik]
jetzt ist der boden schön glatt und ich
gebe es ins gefrierfach da wird einfach
am schnellsten fest es dauert also etwa
15 bis 20 minuten und ich zeige euch
schon mal die zutaten für die erste
creme für die schokoladencreme brauche
ich 150 gramm sahne 150 gramm frischkäse
125 gramm quark 30 gramm puderzucker
vier teelöffel seiner fahrt und 100
gramm herren schokolade für die creme
habe ich die herren schokolade schon
geschmolzen einfach über dem warmen
wasserbad das darf natürlich nicht mehr
kochen damit es nicht zu heiß ist und
jetzt kann ich hier die sahne bereits
aufschlagen und dann mit nach seiner
fahrt steif schlagen
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich den frischkäse in das
separate so und da nehme ich immer gern
den doppeln frischkäse und datum der
schokolade dazu und das kann ich dann
ganz kurz verrühren
[Musik]
das war schon der ideale brotaufstrich
für mich aber wir machen eine torte also
jetzt weitere hier kommen jetzt auch
puderzucker und dazu weg war natürlich
auch dann macht das ganze so ein
bisschen leichter dass sie dort eben
auch nicht so schwer wird und das
restliche sabbath und die zutaten jetzt
auch ganz kurz einrühren
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich hier noch die sahne dazu
und kann sie bei niedriger stufe ganz
vorsichtig einrühren jetzt die torte
wieder dran
die ist jetzt schön gefroren
beziehungsweise der boden fest jetzt
kommt hier schon mal die erste creme
drauf aber ein drittel hebe ich auf das
brauche ich nämlich dann noch für die
deko
und jetzt einfach die creme schön
verteilt
die torte und die restliche creme kommen
jetzt in den kühlschrank und ich zeige
euch die zutaten für die nächste schicht
für die cappuccino creme brauche ich
einen espresso 30 gramm puderzucker 150
gramm sahne 150 com frischkäse 125 gramm
quark und vier teelöffel seiner party
für die cappuccino creme habe ich jetzt
bereits die sahne mit etwas salat steif
geschlagen und habe jetzt hier in einem
kleinen topf den espresso und
puderzucker und zwar wird es jetzt ein
gekocht damit einfach nicht so viel
flüssigkeit in der creme ist und ich
lasse es jetzt eben so lange kochen bis
sie ruckartig wird also nichts halt
aufpassen noch ein bisschen und die
blume bläschen die werden dann immer
mehr und ab dem punkt könnte dann auch
stoppen und das ganze dann kurz kühl
stellen
und ich zeige euch jetzt noch die zwei
zutaten die wir jetzt für die füllung
brauchen für die füllung brauche ich 200
gramm bis kürzungen oder löffel bist
wird und allen café die bis gezwungen
oder löffel bis wird könnte jetzt im
café tauchen
ihr könnt auch gern zum beispiel
bisschen kaffee liköre eingeben und bei
gar keinen kaffee man kann sie auch ein
bisschen milch eintauchen
[Musik]
jetzt ist die s presse creme abgekühlt
so sieht's jetzt aus und die gebe ich
jetzt in einer schüssel gemeinsam mit
dem quark und stimmt frischkäse
hier kommen auch das restliche
sonderfahrt mit dazu und wie gerade eben
werde ich jetzt zuerst diese creme
verrühren und dann noch die sahne
unterheben
[Musik]
jetzt kommen die torte wieder seinen
kühlschrank die restlich auch und ich
zeige euch noch die restlichen zutaten
für die dritte creme für die helle creme
traurig 150 gramm sahne 150 gramm quark
drei teelöffel sonderfahrt 30 gramm
puderzucker und einen teelöffel wandel
extrakt für die telekom habe ich die
sache bereits steif geschlagen und jetzt
versuche ich einfach nur noch den quark
mit vanille extrakt dem puderzucker und
im restlichen seiner fahrt und kann
diese dann noch unterheben
[Musik]
und jetzt geht es bereits an die deko
und zwar nämlich einen spritzbeutel mit
einer ganz großen loch thüle hier vorne
und da kommen jetzt alle drei trainings
rein und zwar zuerst die dunkelste also
die schokocreme dann die cappuccino krim
und darüber die helle sahne creme
[Musik]
jetzt seht ihr hier schon den leichten
farbverlauf und das haben wir jetzt
gleich auf der torte fange ich außen an
zu spritzen und werde jetzt einfach nach
innen hin eine spirale 10
[Musik]
und ich habe jetzt einfach zwei
schichten übereinander gemacht und jetzt
kommen die torte in den kühlschrank am
besten für vier stunden und dann können
wir sehr komplett aus dekorieren und
natürlich auch punkto heranbilden
[Musik]
der murat musste gestern arbeiten da
kann ich den kuchen gestern nicht mehr
an schneiden aber aufgehoben
aufgeschoben ist nicht aufgehoben so und
jetzt habe ich den kuchen aus der
backform bereits herausgelöst und habe
ihn jetzt mit zimt bestreut und bisschen
schokolade drüber geräten der in
building dein handy der kuchen geht vor
also weg gerade angerufen habe der murat
hat dich versetzt wegen einem stück
kuchen kann man schon so sagen oder
einfach die kombination café ich mag
einfach kaffee und süßigkeiten eine
kombination morgen
ich weiß auch gar nicht wert ist deinen
lieblings kaffee kuchen ist der monats
liebling für dein geburtstag oder der
monats liebling in meinem klein six buch
oder da hier hast du warst schon kaffee
mehr süßspeisen als er am schnellsten
verwalten haupt muss ich sagen ich hab
ja auch älter und mein finger
das sieht richtig gut aus so tom mal
wieder aussieht lakers müssen so oben
will
da sucht vorsicht da rutscht ich finde
den anstand hier drin so schön guck mal
so dunkel dann die schoko schicht dann
die die die besitzungen die ich noch da
hatte die sind ja auch noch mal
getränken kaffee und richtig cool naja
ich mal was das ist wieso man kann doch
man kann auch die kaufen und nennt sich
das so ein joghurt darf den namen denn
das produkt ration krieg schon ich hätte
vielleicht diesen diesen zott joghurt
wer so schlicht fest
das hast du damals breite einen kuchen
abgesagt jährlich bis heute noch keinen
freien joghurt gekriegt ja aber nicht
westen mit mit kaffee schmeckt genauso
wenig wie der schmeckt der überhaupt zum
nachmachen empfohlen
absolut perfekt dann könnt ihr das
rezept gerne nachlesen ob sallys -
blockte jedoch steht noch mal alles
ganz genau ich probiere auch gleich ein
stückchen gar nicht sein ziel gewesen
eines sonst das ist schön ich glaube das
ist schon sehr groß dass leute lieber
papi mag der kaffeemarkt ist genau
kinder ist natürlich ist kein problem
ein stückchen ja auf jeden fall
stückchen aber ich glaube ich ihnen
melden den kaffeegeschmack vielleicht
nicht aber er schmeckt lecker nach
schokolade also viel spaß beim
nachmachen und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal
[Musik]